prime minister golob thanks for joining
gw now your visit here of course have
been very much dominated by questions of
energy overshadowed by the war in
ukraine president salenski is angry
right now
that canada is providing a turbine to
germany that will be used in nordstrom
one he says that this is a sign of
weakness from the west towards russia
can you see where he's coming from do
you agree with him on that
i agree with him on many things but not
on this one
i believe that right now
ukraine deserves all the support it can
get from europe but europe has to stay
strong in order to provide support
by weakening europe at its heart in
germany at its industrial base it
doesn't help ukraine so yeah i believe
that turbine needs to get back as soon
as possible and if the gas flows resume
that's good sign for europe and
later on for ukraine as well now of
course russian gas is not just about
germany it's about many countries in
europe slovenia included absolutely
slovenia takes more than 80 percent of
its gas 100 percent russia 100 is russia
based even worse than that there's been
a lot of talk about the solidarity
within the european union over gas when
it comes to the winter for example if it
looks like europe is going to freeze but
aren't you concerned that as a small
country slovenia would be at the back of
the line behind giants like germany when
it came to distributing the gas if there
was a real crisis
okay
actually you just mentioned the main
reason why we're pushing for solidarity
on a european basis but then we also
have a backup plan which means that we
already have a solidarity pact with
italy as our large
gas consuming neighbor so we count that
we as a small country together with
italy we can we weather the situation
much better than alone so yeah but again
no single nation can truly uh
know truly find a right solution for the
winter if the gas is switched off by the
russians
we've also been talking a lot of course
about weapons provision to ukraine
um there's been a lot of controversy
some angry criticism around these
processes of swaps
in providing weapons to ukraine whereby
a country like slovenia will provide
some weapons and then germany will
backfill from its stocks to a country
like slovenia
what have you come away with in terms of
your talks with or love schultz today
have you come away with any concrete
decisions
well not yet but i believe we are on the
right track we perhaps we removed from
the table a couple of items which were
blocking
the
talks in the past i believe now the path
is clear which means we can come to a
conclusions within a month
not but on the other hand in parallel to
debt we will not wait we already started
the
measures uh within the army meaning that
we are getting the weapons prepared for
the logistics for the transport because
that's really the most time consuming
thing is to get them prepared and then
shipped to ukraine the the last batch
that we did uh it took like three took
us more than two months just to get it
shipped
now you mentioned that you've removed a
couple of blockages could be you be more
specific what you've achieved today it
was about the common understanding of
what we want to achieve and how to
proceed
i wouldn't i will i wouldn't want to go
into details because it's obviously
classified but yeah there were some
different views on how to proceed and i
think today we came to a common
understanding
germany has had a lot of criticism
particularly from eastern european
countries but from some other quarters
to of of being kind of hesitant on the
provision of weapons of kind of going
slow and making these sort of swap
systems more complicated than they need
to be
do you come away today confident that
germany is really committed to this
to providing as many weapons in as
uncomplicated a way as possible to
ukraine now this is perhaps a
step
to
a step too much but what i believe is
that there of course there are different
nations and we do act in a different
manner there are nations like slovenia
who go gradually and there are nations
like germany who goes like wow all in
and i believe once the industrial base
of germany really
puts all in in also in weapon industry
there's a lot of
huge
let's call them results that we can
expect for the future but it takes a lot
of time to get here but i think we are
close into this step for the future but
what do you think has been holding that
back then what is what's getting in the
way of that it's hard for me to uh judge
the cultural uh the culture of each
nation but in germany it's like
just go back two years and think what
was the reason when the car industry of
germany switched from combustion to
electric this is similar so it took them
longer than americans but once they did
it they did it all in prime minister
golob many thanks for speaking to dw
today
you're welcome